someone walks up to you on the street
and says 2943 quick is this divisible by
nine it's a matter of life and death and
you could say well I can do this fairly
quickly to figure out whether it's
divisible by nine I just have to add up
the digits and figure out if the sum of
the digits is multiple but is a multiple
of nine or whether it's divisible by
nine so let's do that two plus nine plus
four plus three two plus 9 is 11 11 plus
4 is 15 15 plus 3 is 18 and 18 is
definitely divisible by 9 so this is
going to be divisible by 9 and even if
you are unsure whether 18 is divisible
by 9 you can apply the same rule again 1
plus 8 is equal to 9 so that's
definitely definitely divisible by 9 and
so the person can go save their lives or
whoever's life they were trying to save
with that information but this might
leave you thinking well that was nice
and useful but why did that work does
this work for all numbers does it only
work for 9 I don't think this works for
8 or 7 or 11 or 17 why does it work for
9 it actually also works for 3 and we'll
think about that in a future video and
to realize that we just have to rewrite
2943 so the two and 2943 it's in the
thousands place so we can literally
write rewrite it as 2 times 2 times 1000
the 9 is in the hundreds place so we can
read literally write it as 9 times 100
the 4 is in the tens place so it's
literally the same thing as 4 times 10
and then finally we have our 3 in the
ones place we could write it as 3 times
1 or just 3 this is this is literally
2940 and 3 2943 but now we can rewrite
each of these things this thousand this
100 this 10 as the sum of 1 plus
something that is divisible by 9 so a
thousand a thousand I can rewrite as 1
plus 999 1 plus 999 I can rewrite a
hundred as 1 plus 99 1 plus 99
I can rewrite 10 as 1 plus 9 and so two
times a thousand is the same thing as 2
times 1 plus 999 9 times 100 is the same
thing as 9 times 1 plus 99 4 times 10 is
the same thing as 4 times 1 plus 9 and
then I have this plus 3 over here but
now I can distribute I can say well this
over here is the same thing as 2 times 1
which is just 2 plus 2 times 9 9 9 this
thing right over here is the same thing
as 9 times 1 just to be clear what I'm
doing I'm distributing the 2 on that
over the first parenthesis these first
two terms then the 9 I'm going to
distribute again so it's going to be 9 9
times 1 plus 9 times 99 plus 9 times 99
and then over here I forgot the plus
sign right over here I'm going to
distribute the 4 4 times 1 so plus 4 and
then 4 times 9 so plus 4 times 9 and
then finally I have this positive 3 or
plus 3 right over here now I'm just
going to rearrange this addition so I'm
going to take all the terms where I'm
multiplying by 999 and I'm going to do
that in orange so I'm gonna take this
term this term and this term right over
here and so I have 2 times 999 that's
that there plus 9 times 99 plus 4 times
9 plus 4 times 9 so that's those three
terms and then I have plus 2 plus 2 plus
9 plus 9 plus 4 plus 4 and plus 3 plus 3
and this is interesting this is just the
sum of our digits this is just what we
did up here and you might see where all
of this is going this orange stuff here
is this divisible by 9 well sure it well
definitely 999 that's divisible by 9 so
anything that's multiplying by it is
divisible by 9 so this is divisible by 9
this is definitely divisible by 999
regardless of whether it was being
multiplied by 9 whatever is multiplying
by not
being whatever is multiplying 99 it's
gonna be divisible by 9 because 99 is
divisible by 9 so this works out and
same thing over here you're always going
to be multiplying by a multiple of 9 so
all of this business right over here is
definitely going to be divisible by 9
and so in order for the whole thing and
all I did is I rewrote 2943 like this
right over here in order for the whole
thing to be divisible by 9 this part
definitely is divisible by 9 in order
for the whole thing does the rest of
this sum it has to be divisible by 9 as
well so in order for this whole thing
all of this has to be divisible
divisible by 9